hi guys I'm Eric Vox and this is a
breakdown of the walking dead season 7
episode 14 the other side this episode
shows that the best way for two
frenemies to finally see eye to eye is
to go on a suicide mission together it
also left us with this mystery shadow
which is clearly best guys come on
hashtag goats baths and I'll get to that
later but there's a lot to cover in this
episode and let's get started with these
opening images so this episode has one
of the more interesting openings that
we've seen this season a full 5 minutes
with no words whatsoever just a montage
from around the hilltop and the first
thing we see is this shot of Maggie as
she transitions from a blurry unfocused
state to this sharp focus close-up as
the people of the hilltop work around
her I think this is meant to convey
Maggie's clear vision as a strong leader
as the hilltop gears up for war we see
shots of the blacksmith making spearhead
and Maggie teaching the hilltop cannon
fodder how to throw a knight and Maggie
riding up to do list so this is what a
good wartime leader does she realizes it
requires a team effort patience and
strategy but remember this episode is
called the other side and I think it's
titled that because it shows the duality
of one side facing another opposing side
and in this opening montage that other
side is Sasha
all of these opening shots contrast what
it means to be a true leader like Maggie
with what it means to be a lone warrior
like Sasha
unlike Maggie Sasha is shown to be alone
throughout all this brooding as she
prepares for war in her own way and the
conclusion of these images is that true
leaders are rewarded with community and
life symbolized by Maggie looking at her
ultrasound where as lone warriors only
find loneliness and death symbolized by
Sasha stacking rocks on Abraham's grave
and during this montage we get this
moment with Maggie and Daryl notice how
Daryl refuses to look at or talk to her
now we later learn why Daryl still feels
guilt for Glen's death but it's cool how
they're able to communicate this to us
non-verbally I also like that we see
Maggie regaining her composure before
she heads back inside a true leader we
also see the opposite of a true leader
with Gregory suspiciously watching them
from inside at Maggie and the other
Hilltoppers clearly talk [ __ ] about them
like rather than doing anything to be
part of this war effort we
only ever see Gregory cowering inside
his office getting drunk and trying to
spit game with the Savior's okay moving
on after the credits to Maggie and Jesus
now Jesus reveals some of his backstory
here that he grew up in a group home and
one other little detail that from the
comics but not yet revealed on the show
hard getting close to anyone neighbors
friends boyfriend so yeah this kind of
recontextualizes who Jesus was looking
at in the episode last season and Jesus
talks about how bringing Maggie and
Sasha into the community has in turn
made him feel more part of the community
and when Sasha hears this she hangs back
now why does he do it that's because
unlike Jesus and Maggie Sasha does not
want to feel part of the hilltops
because she knows that she's about to
leave it behind
and real quick notice how Maggie
suggests to Jesus that they need right
here things that we really need right I
think that's a little callback to Glenn
Maggie remembers that right here was the
reason he was able to escape the prison
in one piece and then after Jesus
catches Sasha taking his bullet Sasha
hands off this friendship bracelet that
she made for Maggie's baby to eat it and
I was the parallelism between this
handmade gift and the other one that we
see this episode a necklace made by
Rosita initially for Abraham and in both
cases these end up being kind of Olive
Branch peace offerings between these
women like both items were initially
intended for someone else but Sasha and
Rosita allowed these things to be
carried on by Enid and Sasha as a sign
of trust between the women and then with
Kyle announces that the Savior's were
coming Sasha and Rosita stayed through
this secret tunnel that Sasha dug
revealing that the exit strategy on
Maggie's to-do list earlier was actually
follow through on Latasha also mentions
the title this episode the attack now as
I mentioned before the other side
doesn't just refer to the outside of the
hilltop walls it refers to the two sides
of opposition meeting and working out
their differences and by taping together
on this mission these two opposing
forces Sasha and Rosita still angry with
each other from the Abraham love
triangle last season will finally begin
to understand the other side okay moving
on to this scene between gregory and
simon and by the way simon has been
super fun to watch of all the actors to
play surrogate for negan
even August been the closest we seem to
actually matching jeopardy Morgan
swagger as Meegan kind of like that mix
of hey friend just lighten up I'm just
joking but also I'm taking your [ __ ] and
I'll kill you if you try to stop me and
then note this exchange between them gin
man right man of shifting specifics
tasting transition I'm into tequila now
now Gregory is referring to episode 5
when Simon took his Scott to mention
that he was a gin man this is scotch
well not just hate this stuff tastes
like ashtrays and window cleaner I'm a
gin man and the fact that Gregory
remembers this shows that he's trying to
placate Simon with little personal
details about him kind of like those
old-school networking notes people would
write on rolodexes which by the way is
the thing that I only really know about
from the office Paul and beat anyway
Simon now says that his taste in liquor
are constantly shifting for Simon this
is a counter tactic he doesn't want
details about him to be on anyone's
rolodex like Meighan he prides himself
and being unpredictable in kind of a
mystery that is how he inspired fear and
exerts his authority we actually saw the
Joker use a similar technique in the
dark night remember revising his sack
story throughout the movie my father
a drinker sticks the blade in my mouth
let's put a smile on that face so I had
a wife who gambled one day they part of
her face I stick a laser in my mouth and
do this okay moving on to Rosita and
Sasha trying to hotwire this car and
Rosita seen Sasha wearing that necklace
that she made for Abraham and at this
point things are still very tense and
bitter between the two like notice how
the camera is literally placed between
the actors in these tight close-ups
where they look directly into the camera
it's kind of awkward to have actors look
directly into the lens it's not common
on the show but they do it here to bring
the viewer into this awkward tension
between the characters and after this
moment Sasha and Rosita don't really
make eye contact again until the
characters make peace later on also
notice for Zetas line here and then she
sees the next life that remembers
Abraham - I think Rosita is implying
some double meaning here
she thought Abraham was the one - and
now he's dead Rosita with the wordplay
then we get another rare shot for the
walking dead one long unbroken take
running a total of a minute and 10
seconds including this rather
complicated move of Rosita and Sasha
taking down Walker's at the same time so
why did they shoot it this way I think
they wanted naturalism here allowing the
actors to deliver this bitter argument
in raw real time and then organically
build to them working together to clear
an obstacle these two have come a long
way from rivals to friends and this
transitional shot is one of the key
steps of that transition also notice the
exchange between them over whether to
shoot negan from afar or infiltrate the
community and get them up close wait -
from a distance in midst we don't get
another chain I won't miss even if you
should engrave him he doesn't die I
won't miss now I'm not sure if Sasha
realizes the stage he's throwing at
Rashida right here but I won't miss
reminds us of episode 8 when Rosita had
negan right in her sights point-blank
range and missed hitting Lucille instead
which is why Rosita is so determined to
go in close this time so that they won't
blow their second shot if it's too now
back at the hilltop in it tries to stall
this savior named Roy from going into
the basement where Maggie and Daryl are
hiding so why is Roy
such a grammar nazi' I've got fresh
veggies enough they're vegetables use
the whole word we have time so the
shortened word veggies isn't even bad
grammar but I think the point of this
other than to implies possible backstory
being the most annoying English teacher
or just one of those weird internet
trolls in a comment section who make big
deals on the nothing really this moment
is saying you can't rush this guy he's
thorough so that sets up the tension
when he takes his time in the basement
later on also
why doesn't eated have to hide from the
Savior's like the rest of her people
so unlike Maggie Daryl Sasha and Rosita
Enid wasn't present for the big negan
lineup and I don't think the Savior's
ever saw or noticed her in Alexandria so
in a way she's invisible to them able to
hide in plain sight and then small
detail here the produce in the basket is
cucumbers and cantaloupes it looks like
which aren't veggies or vegetables but
these are both significant foods from
the past hilltop cucumbers for the same
ones that were used to make the pickles
that Eugene ate at the sanctuary when he
seemingly switched sides and cantaloupes
from the kingdom led to Benjamin Seth
last episode and yeah I feel like there
could be a connection here like maybe
Enid will help avenge Benjamin the
cantaloupe death by killing Eugene the
cucumber pickle and I am not at all a
crazy person just reading into things
this produce metaphor theory is 100%
going to happen okay moving on to Simon
and dr. Harlan Carson proving the theory
from episode 11 that the other dr.
Carson that negan reference after he
killed dr. Emmett Carson was this guy
his brother Harlan at the hilltop and
when Harlan realizes his brother has
died his reaction is interesting another
piston one off himself killed this kind
of implies that Harlan and his brother
might not have been on good terms like
in one point the two dr. brothers parted
ways like how in real life some doctors
choose to be pediatricians and small
farming communities while other doctors
cash in with a few jobs in psycho
fascist cult classic scenario really
also Simon reveals what is in that crate
that saviors have been lugging around
tons and tons of aspirin now this is
insulting on more than one level for one
a bunch of painkillers obviously aren't
a fair trade for an actual doctor like I
don't think
aspirin tablets are going to deliver
Maggie's baby but it's also kind of
insulting for dr. Carson like you think
this is what I'm worth what do you think
doctors do okay moving on to Darryl and
Maggie in the basement now like Rosita
and Sasha there's been this awkward
tension between these two all episodes
as they've avoided eye contact but
instead of Abraham being the elephant in
the room it's the other martyr Glenn
sterile field guilty for Glenn's death
with his swing at negan in episode 1
leading to Meighan taking it out on
Glenn and this absolution is meant to
parallel the one that we see between
Rosita and Sasha later on but again we
see that contrast between true leaders
and lone warriors Maggie into telling
Daryl that she wanted to kill that
Savior as well but she held off because
she knows winning the overall war
requires patience meanwhile Rose Sasha's
Union results in a desire to act out
recklessly and then outside notice how
Gregory glances around nervously as the
Hilltoppers glare at him for giving up
dr. Carson it looks like he's afraid of
being literally stabbed in the back
Julius Caesar style and now that we know
that he has directions for the sanctuary
I feel like this fear of losing power
will drive him to throw a wrench into
all of it and when the truck pulls away
with Carson the exhaust blows right over
him like way to give your only doctor
respiratory issues I also feel like this
kind of parallels the fate of its
brother who was thrown into fire and
smoke by the Savior's so after Rosita
and Tasha learned the value of teamwork
via grand theft auto these to finally
settle their differences as they wait to
get a clear shot at Meegan Rosita
reveals more of her backstory that she
learned how to hotwire cars and defuse
bombs and tie knots from three guys that
she dated who were all apparently
brothers like these guys were all the
sons of Sarah Connor
but Rosita assured Sasha that Abraham
was different because rather than seeing
her as this helpless baby bird that he
needed to protect he valued her as a
real partner so what's talking about
Rosita showing Saucer how to tie this
knot you teach me those knot I know a
bunch but not those all matters right so
on one level this teaching moment
reflects Rosita and Sasha
tying the knot in a sense finding a
common ground in forming a union and
this knot kind of connects to Sasha's
friendship bracelet from earlier which
if you remember was left untied and
incomplete now Rosita it's teaching
how to tie a knot to complete it but
also Sasha hinting that this knot could
come in handy
kind of feels like it could be
foreshadowing something to come like I
bet there's a good chance we're going to
see Sasha tie a knot to get out of a jam
in the sanctuary or maybe tie a noose
for herself if she gets taken captive I
don't know we'll see the scene also
gives us more insight into the Eugene
mystery like has this guy really crossed
over to this other side of saviours to
have a few stops on that first quick
shout-out to our friends at audible now
I know I go super in-depth into these
Walking Dead breakdowns and a big reason
why I'm able to do that is by listening
to Walking Dead audiobooks through
audible audible offers a wide selection
of audiobooks and podcasts and you can
get a free audiobook with a 30-day trial
at audible.com slash new rockstars one
audiobook that I really liked was Robert
Kirkman's The Walking Dead invasion
written by Jay bond and singer and
narrated by Fred Berman who also
narrated search-and-destroy which I've
recommended in the past I use audible
all the time driving walking around
doing the dishes while I'm in the shower
which is kind of coming in at you
because once a good chapter I get all
prunes but it's so worth this so like me
you can turn your shower into something
more in a non gross way with a free
trial at audible.com slash new rockstars
to start now okay back to Eugene so
notice how they see him ordering Walker
fortifications with grimly Gunks the
monkey in his pocket and then later they
hear his radio command in which he
confirms his loyalty to negan in the
most redundant way any questions should
be directed or strong dr. Eugene order
chief engineer also known as Meghan well
I am so it's interesting that even after
all of this
Rosita's interpretation is that Eugene
is working an angle this is a big deal
it wasn't too long ago that she viewed
Eugene as a useless coward so the fact
that she assumed he hasn't betrayed them
as appears to be the case but is
actually working as a double agent for
them shows that Rosita really has
changed her mindset
but it's she right to assume this about
Eugene like is this really an act or is
Eugene genuinely loyal to Meegan and I
know more and more it looks like Eugene
has indeed turned on his old friends
especially by the end of this episode
but I will say the fact that Eugene
keeps feeling the need to reassure
everyone that he
it's vegan in this awkward way repeating
that's who I am and correcting PDQ
pretty damn quick to psq pretty [ __ ]
quick who sound more like Megan it all
just sounds insincere to me like I get
that he would be nervous back in episode
11 when he was still new but now the guy
is chief engineer a top-ranking savior
and if he was truly loyal to Meegan I
don't think he would sound this
desperate to prove his loyalty again and
again I don't know it's just my two
cents I'll come back to you Jean but
first we get this scene between Jesus
and Gregory's now Gregory tries to
divide and conquer his threats to his
power by giving Maggie job assignments
and ordering that she can't live with
Jesus anymore and then notice what he
says to Cal about the tequila crystal
conformer which is that is the same
phrasing that Simon used earlier crack
opium tequila and I think this fanboy
crushed that Gregory has on Simon's will
come back as a problem for Maggie in the
near future and then moving on to this
final scene at the sanctuary
Azim disgusted security with this other
Savior who then gets taken down and
that's out of nowhere headshot which
seems like a callback to Axl says that
season three at the prison and then we
come back to this question if Eugene is
working against negan
why wouldn't he escaped with Rosita and
Sasha when given the chance but if you
think about it it actually kind of makes
sense for Eugene's like he can see that
their plan is not that well thought-out
it's just the two of them no Rick no
Maggie no backup it's literally a
suicide mission
in fact it's a lot like the suicide
mission proposed new gene by the other
two women in the sanctuary in episode 11
which he also refused to take part in so
I feel like once again Eugene is
sticking to his own long game because he
has the most confidence that unlike
everyone else he's actually put a ton of
thought into his plan and it'll maximize
his chances for survival now I could be
totally wrong and Eugene will orally
disappoint all of us I think a good sign
of that will be if he ends up snitching
on Rosita and Sasha we'll see and then
when Sasha tricks Rosita and runs off in
a sanctuary alone it's less of an act of
betrayal than it is an act of love like
now that Sasha truly understands who
Rosita is and what she can do Sasha
knows that Rosita's diverse skill sets
are more useful to their people
whereas sasha has always been better
on her own as a killer and the closing
images of the episode leave us with this
mystery who is this shadowy figure
approaching Rosita well obviously it
looks like the figure has a crossbow
strapped to its back making me think
that this is white like we've all been
waiting for Dwight to turn on negan and
helping Rosita could be a good way to
finally do that but let's look more
closely at this shot and adjust the
brightness in the contrast
actually that looks pretty clearly like
Darrell remember Darrell did get a new
crossbow from the kingdom and he was
wearing it earlier when he realized
Rosita and Sasha were missing also
Darrell does know how to get to the
sanctuary so I feel like this
cliffhanger was designed as a fake out
to look like blight when really it's
Darrell come to get repeated out of
there now will they be able to save
Sasha too or will her tortured soul
cross over to the other side okay
looking ahead to next episode episode 15
titled something they need the sneak
peak scene shows Maggie actually saying
these words to Gregory they're something
emanate something they need being the
revenge that Rosita and Sasha are
seeking and the fact that Gregory
implies that all of her friends are
missing is even more evidence that yeah
it was Darrell in that final shot and in
a promo for the last two episodes of the
season we see that Gregory is holding a
knife behind his back in the scene so
even though it seems like he's trying to
make peace with Maggie
I really think his ultimate strategy is
way more evil also I'm not sure if it'll
be next episode of the season finale but
the promo also shows a return to
Oceanside and an explosion there making
me think that Rick will get the guns
that he needs but you may have to take
them by force also it looks like Aaron's
boyfriend named Erik will be joining
them and considering this guy never goes
on missions
I feel like this doesn't bode well for
him one bit and some lingering questions
one was Sasha right to think that she
not Rosita was more expendable like to
be honest decide to choose between them
Rosita constant anger at everything with
a pulse is way more exhausting but I
understand why Sasha made this decision
I mean hey someone's got to make
Alexandria's necklaces right and - do
you think there's been enough negan this
season of The Walking Dead like jeopardy
Morgan it's such a huge presence on this
show and I feel like that
larger-than-life persona has been kind
of limited on this season now I
understand that jeopardy Morgan probably
gets paid a lot for
episode but it's just kind of going to
go through these long stretches where
negan only shows up over the radio or
through a sniper scope and as much as I
love Simon's character it seems like he
was just brought in so that they
wouldn't have to use negan as much I
don't know maybe able to see a nitpicky
but let me know what you think in the
comments and be sure to check out all my
other breakdowns at sequel 7 episodes
thanks for watching and if you liked
this video please hit like and subscribe
to do rock stars
also please share this video and if you
really like new rock stars you can
contribute to us on patreon thank you so
much to all of our current patrons you
guys are awesome you can hit me up on
Twitter at EA vas with any thoughts you
have on the walking dead or follow do
rock stars on Twitter at new rockstars
for updates on our videos alright thanks
for watching bye